he's Mitchell true biscay former North
Carolina quarterback and he joins us
know where are you Mitchell today I'm in
Mentor Ohio back in my hometown having
lunch with my brother my HD all right
what have you been doing since bottom
the last two months how would you sum
that up uh I've been workin out training
throwing those of my receivers doing
private workouts for teams and traveling
and do a lot of meeting visits and
interviews what is the private workout
like well uh the the coach the team
whoever wants to work me out they come
to chapel hill because that's where the
worker has to be done so i have my
receivers and running backs out there
with me and they just put me through a
workout so basically i'm throwing to my
receivers i'm doing their individual
quarterback drills and it's like a mini
practice with that team and they just
want to see how i throw and and see how
i do drills and watch me throw my
receivers who would surprise me it came
down to work you out um I don't know
bears brown Jets 49ers and bills those
are the teams yep any odd request know
when you do a private workout um not
really them I mean it's just throwing so
there's nothing really odd about it just
come out there and thrown and they've
seen me throw a lot so I just want to
confirm in person what they see on tape
how about the interviews are they
different than what you had at the
combine or any other time I would say
they're a lot more laid back in some
summer interview questions about me
other times it's learning their offense
so they like to see how fast I could
pick up things and it's it's a little
bit more laid back so I just go in there
get to the coaches coaches get to know
mean we just talked football who'd you
grow up liking team eyes I like the I
grew up room for Browns just a hometown
team and you know what about quarterback
I like Dan Marino as a kid growing up
and then uh
Manning have you met either one I talked
to pay Manning on the phone wait how
that happened I've just just got my
number and was able to talk to him and
ask her some advice by going through the
process and all that wait so Peyton
called you through we just my college
coach Coach fedora was able to get him
on the phone for me yeah yeah okay he's
Mitch Mitchell true biscay Allah was
made of that change from Mitch to from
Mitch to Mitchell it felt like right why
it wasn't it wasn't really a change I
would say I think people try to make it
into that the question got just got
thrown out of proportion and bass me
what I prefer and I said I don't really
care my mom calls me Mitchell and people
close to my family called Mitchell but
I've been called Mitch Mitchell my whole
life so it's not like I was changing my
name or anything it was just just
answering the questions I thought I was
doing some big deal but it's not big
deal really I've told the coaches that
they call them mature Mitchell it really
doesn't matter it doesn't really bother
to me well my mom would call me Daniel
but that's usually when I was in trouble
so I don't know when you got in trouble
if your mom you know would yell out
Mitchell true biscay oh no she called me
Mitchell David oh oh oh yeah then you
knew it was trouble a didn't get in too
much trouble but when she needed me or
if somewhat serious note you're coming
what's your nickname I only have one
dollar school is mr. Biskit qb1 wait
wait wait wait back to mr. is mr. Biskit
give me way how do we come up with mr.
biscuit so when I first got there is
like a freshman from the coaches were
out one night and I guess what her
family members was talking about me and
kind of studded or murmured my first and
last name together and uh one of the
coaches thought they said mr. biscuit
and then it just kind of caught on
practice and next week and uh so it was
mr. biscuits and
the football was the biscuits throw it
on the biscuits to fish them out dude I
smell a sponsorship here I'm that
wouldn't be a bad thing I'm a big fan of
sausage egg cheese and biscuits yum I
get mr. biscuit or deal uh do you know
how you know we're always looking to see
how many games somebody's played would
you play 13 games start 13 games at
North Carolina is that is that a good i
started started a 13-play 230 okay oh
okay so you're ready for that question
so how much is enough sample size do you
think for somebody to be able to assess
how a quarterback is going to play in
the NFL uh that's not really for me to
say I mean I I know I'm ready I think
I've shown from my tapes and starting
and then the previous year that I have
more than enough pass attempts and seen
enough defenses to be able to go in and
leader NS often so there's no there's no
one right number of number of starts
remember past attempts to show that you
could be successful in the NFL so it's
just my job to take the pic step learn
the offense and it continues to grow as
a quarterback but I know I'm ready how
important is it to go number one uh to
me it's not really that important it's
it's more about getting with the right
team and and all that stuff is out of my
control so i'm just showing the coaches
who i am and they know what type of
player I am and what I can bring to it
organization so wherever I go I hope I
match up with a bunch of great coaches
that believe in me and I'm gonna give
the organization everything I got where
are you going to be on draft night I
want to be in Philadelphia with my
family and the friends so i'll be up to
draft well good luck and be a whirlwind
tour and by the way i don't know what
you're going to wear but understand that
ten years down the road when we look
back you want to be proud of what you
were wearing so don't don't go crazy all
right oh yeah it's not my style you can
give you know like a carolina blue
there's nothing wrong with having like a
pocket hankie or something like
something there if you want to give a
shout out to to the tar heels but don't
don't go zo Elliott or anything like
that
I just you know your agent Megan I give
you this advice there mr. biscuit so I
just want to help you so they're on top
of it okay good probably all right well
have fun and thanks for joining us
Mitchell first share thank you and I
Mitchell true biscay your biscuit I love
them the Dan Patrick show weekday
mornings on audience